hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll you
all know if you're a listener here that
I am on the complexity bandwagon I think
that complex systems are really
interesting I mean maybe that's just
kind of obvious maybe everyone thinks
complex systems are interesting the
question is can we make progress
thinking about complexity in and of
itself in other words there is a human
being here is an economy here is the
Milky Way galaxy these are three
complicated systems do they have
anything in common does it make sense to
study the idea of complexity as a field
of study rather than just studying the
individual examples of it separately so
I think that it does make sense and I
think that we don't have the answers yet
we don't have a fully fleshed out theory
for how best to think about complexity I
did the recent podcast with David
krackow where I suggested that maybe we
should think of complexity science S as
pre paradigmatic he didn't like that he
says he thinks that there's a paradigm
out there which is great it's great that
people disagree about this I mean maybe
we actually agree on the substance and
are just slightly disagreeing about the
words but one way you can make progress
on thinking about complexity is to
really narrow in on a particular kind of
complex system and study it from all
angles and if that's true then what
better kind of complex system to study
than the brain or not just the human
brain in its biological specificity but
the idea of an intelligent brain okay so
of course you can study the brain you
can be a neuroscientist etc etc but you
can also take a step back you can
abstract you can say okay I think that a
human brain is intelligent it has
thoughts it does reasoning we are also
kind of talking about artificial forms
of intelligence right so what are the
general principles here what are the
general circumstances under which a
system of any sort can be thought of as
thinking as doing cognition as being
intelligent what is the space of all
possible cognitions and how do you get
there right how do you get there in
biological evolution how do you get
there in design what are the different
phases so do you need it to be kind of a
solid structure you know the brain in
the human being is kind of squishy but
it's still mostly solid the neurons are
hooked up to each other in more or less
a predictable way whereas if you look at
the flight of Starlings for example
right a flock of birds communicating
with their nearest neighbors can you
think about that as a kind of collective
intelligence what about ant colonies or
bee colonies is there some thinking
going on is there some intelligence that
is not from Individual neurons hooked up
in a rigid way but rather from
Individual units that can move around
and flow into each other in different
ways so you have solid brains you have
liquid brains you have artificial brains
what's going on what is the space of all
possible ways of thinking well if that's
interesting to you you've come to the
right place that's what we're talking
about today with Rickard sole who is the
head of the complex systems Lab at The
catalon Institute for research and
advanced studies in Barcelona also
external professor at the Santa Fe
Institute and he's trained as a
physicist but like many people in this
area he has let his curiosity fly around
and he's ended up thinking about exactly
this question how complexity develops
what is the space of possible cognitions
what kind of architectures are there for
information to flow in a network that
you and I would recognize as something
intelligent something doing some kind of
cognition that might help this kind of
thing might help not only in thinking
about biology but in designing ing
intelligent agents whether it's
artificial intelligence in a silicon
based computer or maybe synthetic
biology when we're in there editing the
genes to making new to make new kinds of
organisms that might qualify as being
intelligence so again very much along
the lines that we support here at
mindscape which is that the basic
Research into these Grand Concepts will
if you do it correctly pay off down the
road in specific ways of think thinking
about really down toe systems so Ricard
is a great guy to talk to about these
things we we go over a wild bunch of
things it's a lot of fun in the
conversation so hope you enjoy it let's
[Music]
go Ricard solay welcome to the mindscape
podcast cast thanks for having me here
so the space of cognitions is the phrase
that has appeared in uh talks that I've
heard you give and articles you've
written that's just a very exciting
concept the space of cognitions do we
understand that very well is this a
well-known thing or are we just trying
to develop the
concept yeah no it's it's a still an
ongoing an ongoing research um the the
ambition here was when you speak people
uh you know you people speaking about um
you know uh cognition in very different
uh kinds of biological systems um often
times you feel like things should be
much better defined and something that
we launch at the Santa Fe Institute in
in a workship was the idea of trying to
kind of map the cognition Space by
including things that go go go from what
we call the solid brains which means our
brain for example with neurons located
in specific position and where all the
fun happens in the interconnections
right whereas in nature you have Al
colonies the immune system uh it's
plenty of interesting stuff there that
doesn't involve that kind of picture of
of fixed neurons in space but instead
they move around and they process
information in different ways so how do
we put all this together and that's kind
of the ambition and just so that the
audience knows sort of how to
triangulate where we are here this
sounds pretty darn interdisciplinary
right like actual brains um but also
Collective brains and ant colonies or
the immune system and also AI kinds of
things right uh it sounds like a lot of
training is involved in figuring this
out yeah of course and and in fact this
this ambition of mapping the commission
space come come from our interest in
understanding whether or not there are
general laws uh for complex systems in
particular general laws that Define or
constrain the the the possibilities that
Evolution can explore in terms of
language cognition sentience and and
yeah I mean um this is a very much
interdisciplinary effort and artificial
intelligence comes now as an interesting
item because of course you can ask now
maybe much better than two decades ago
whether or not uh So-Cal artificial
intelligence will be similar or not than
ours right and way contributing to the
question that I'm really really
fascinated about is what what kind of
possible things can Evolution generate
and whether or not this big convergence
so even for artificial intelligence
maybe you will find out in the end the
same kind of design principles we'll see
well that that's good because I was just
going to ask you mentioned the
possibility of general laws governing
the behavior of complex systems that's a
pretty frequently mentioned ambition in
the complex systems spaces that you and
I move in so what do you think are we
going to get general rules or or is it
more like we should settle for a bunch
of specific rules applying to different
contexts I hope I hope we do I mean it's
of course it's not a simple task at all
um even even as you know even agreeing
in what exactly complexity means um
sometimes a bit controversial for me the
definition comes from emergence
essentially this idea that like in a
termite Nest termites construct this
amazing structures which are thousand
times larger than the individuals
whereas individuals are blind they
communicate in very simple way so you
can spend your whole life looking at
individuals you'll never figure out how
the collective creates the the hyper
structure yeah and besides besides that
I mean there's a lot of ideas that comes
from very different areas and that's
kind of the part of the trip we need to
figure out from theoretical or
statistical physics and computational
theory and we have to blend Concepts
from all of them but personally I think
for example uh sometimes people
discusses the idea of whether or not
life in another planet or in an
alternative biosphere will be different
from from the one we know and I pretty
convinc that um it might seem different
but the basic logic of life is probably
Universal and unique okay well that
that's a very good open question and
hopefully we will get some data on it uh
within our lifetimes that would be very
exciting so speaking of life then I mean
let's let's back up we're talking about
the space of all cognitions that that
gets us excited a little bit of
foreshadowing but let's just get to
cognition in the first place can you can
you say I don't know how you yourself
think about the evolution of cognition
is it just you know one in a series of
major transitions that happened in
evolution or is it something special
yeah that's very good question well I
think that if you think in terms of
again General law of complexity one of
the things that I think and that's where
cognition is is so important that is
probably a part of the explanation of
why the biosphere is complex and not as
somebody said what is not just field of
microbes right or replicators very
simple where is this all complexity
coming from and the the answer to that
is that there's a big payoff in
predicting the future and being able to
gather information from the environment
and respond to that in adaptive ways
right and that that propels brains that
that's kind of the engine of cognition
in evolution and that can come from this
first simple cells where we still need
to figure out when when those cells were
able to use information and when those C
were able to do computations right
because this this is something that is
at the
the I will say in the crossroad between
biology and physics and then uh I will
agree with what you mentioned that
across Evolution I think there are
several cognitive transitions that have
been happening
right so there's I always think of it in
terms of a pay U what what is the word
tradeoff kind of thing right where as
you say you want to be able to predict
the future the world is a scary
unpredictable place it's complex all by
itself even without organisms in it and
so we might want to process information
and make predictions but that costs
energy it C it makes us vulnerable in
different ways but it but it evolved
nevertheless what do we know about that
Evolution that you know how how does one
little neuron help
us well if you look at the at the at the
basic units uh clearly the the invention
of neurons uh is one of the big
transition sh
um you know all every single cell we
know there are systems that are far from
equilibrium that they they maintain
themselves because they create these
gradients between outside and inside and
and that's kind of the first step that
Wass something that um cannot only
create this difference of ions from the
internal and external medium but use
those to propagate information and I
always tell my students actually it's
beautiful to say to see neurons as this
kind of specialized cell type you see
cells from the liver or the kidney they
have these special functionalities which
have to do with metabolic things but
neurons when you look at neurons you see
something that wants to communicate
that's that's why the the shpe is as it
is it wants information right and that
was a big revolution in the so it going
back then is it is there any sense in
which a single cell thinks about the
world a single cell organism I should
say well it's it's it's a bit of
controversy here because um I I
personally think that um is too often in
the in the last decades two decades I
will say it's too often um misus the
term like uh sentience or or
understanding from single cell organism
I will say that we have a good deal of
understanding of what they do and they
do use something that uh we believe was
kind of fundamental in some of the
revolutions to SCA which is associative
learning this capacity of learning and
connecting different kind of um external
items right um and they can do that and
plans can do that and but I I personally
think there not much more than that
right not the kind of the the kind of
memory storage that is so spectacular in
other in other Al but even that sounds
kind of impressive to me I mean what
what does it mean to say that a single
cell bacterium I guess does associative
learning uhuh it is it is so the the the
thing is that they can gather
information and you can actually
engineer that in the lab also you put
complexity there uh so that they can
gather information in a natural way
about about some kind of signal but
under an environment where there are
some external stress that appears
correlated with that signal they
eventually are able to recognize that
stress signal right decorrelated from
the natural original signal that they
are
abated I see okay so it's kind of the
path of dogs diversion and single cell
version I see so there there's something
bad and they recognize there's a
correlation between this bad thing and
this other signal and then they start
responding to the signal whether or not
the actual original bad thing is there
and that's learning I okay I get it
that's that actually makes sense how do
they do that like where in the cell do
they store that information I I I get
the feeling from talking to you and
other people that cells are more
complicated than I give them credit
for yeah they they are very complicated
and and as you as you probably know I
mean uh we actually talk about the the
cell the Genome of cells that are very
small kind the minimal cells and we
still ignore a lot of what many genom
there do um but the thing is that they
have these signaling networks that
gather information from the membrane you
can imagine as a kind of cables going
from the the the membrane into into the
genome or the nuclei depending what kind
of s is that and in a way it reminds us
kind of a neural network except that
this neural network um it's just an
analogy I mean what whatever is there is
being fixed by Evolution and then they
can
store information in for example in
switches all right in within cell we
have switches that allow to store bits
of
information but sorry sorry what kind of
what kind of literal switches are we
talking about like a chemical that can
be one way or the other I'm not like
what kind of what's a switch the usual
the usual thing is genetic switches okay
so uh and actually the logic of that we
know it very well is usually uh switches
that involve two genes that regulate
negative each other so I try to inhibit
you you try to inhibit me right to
repress and that allows to store memory
right it's it's pretty much in a way
what happens in electronics okay is it
actually editing the DNA or the RNA or
just expressing it
differently um well in G regulation it's
is expression right whether or not a
given protein appear years or not so me
that way it's kind of binary okay good
all right good that i' I've learned
something already if if our connection
dies now it' be worthwhile podcast but I
want more so do we know when along the
evolutionary progress uh the first
neuron came to
be okay it's uh it's ongoing discussion
because it's this uh is very recent
research by a number of groups um
the first neurons have to appear in a
context that has to do with
multicellularity because neurons by by
definition at the the least is that and
that's the origin of that so the
beginning were cells that were able to
uh act as
receptors and the cells themselves were
able to detect something and secrete
some signal but this still exists
there's a lot of cells that do that um
but you don't send signals to to in
principle to anyone else the the
beginnings is that receptors are able to
kind of gather information in in simple
ways but that information within the
organism is not kind of propagating all
around got it for that you you need
further Evolution okay good so the first
I I always like it when something
complicated can be broken down into
steps where you can see why each step
would make sense so first we receive a
signal from either the outside world or
maybe even inside the organism itself
it could be yes yeah and then we just do
that something with it ourselves but
then the next step to being a neuron is
talking to other neurons I
suppose exactly exactly in in a way and
it makes sense that this happens
eventually I mean before before the cam
explosion that happened um 50 550 years
I have to remember all was million years
ago before that we had a biosphere
essentially with with very simple
organisms that perform functionalities
like filtering water pretty pretty Bing
stuff um but to evolve the first
Predators which in a way uh was a big
revolution that changed everything you
need to have sensors and the sensors
have to integrate the information and
that's that's probably the key and I
think is a pretty reasonable idea that
if you have to move in an environment
right not just being settling out you
have to move in an environment that is
uncertain you need to integrate
information and the fact you need to
integrate and in a way predict it's it's
probably the engine that you know make
brains happen and the idea is is this
before or after the idea of predation I
I've been told that you know once
animals or once organisms start eating
or other organisms a whole bunch of new
capacities need to be
developed yeah yeah absolutely um we're
talking about metazone and so
multicellular systems um because I mean
predation is also in the in the realm of
of bacteria they Predator bacteria also
right but in for Animals uh yeah
predation came with ice and the nervous
system so um once this started to be in
place you had a whole a whole biosphere
of four animals is just sitting there
unable to escape and that promoted a a a
huge arm race right right of developing
defenses against predators Etc and that
changed everything yeah okay good and
the arms Ray centers I'm going to boldly
conjecture this and you can correct me
uh around information in some sense I'm
still trying to for my own sake figure
out how the process by which organisms
got better at using information I mean
in some sense a bacterium uses a little
bit of information right a gradient more
nutrient in One Direction than another
Direction but it's not really thinking
about the information in the way we
usually think about
it yes yes right I I will say that there
are two major events here that have to
be considered one is um as I was saying
before that um movement movement was
crucial because without movement you you
don't have predators really and that
require the nervous system and and the
other thing um was the development of of
sensors um and for doing that and
integrating information you need another
Revolution which is interneurons right
okay so uh the elements that they are
not just detecting signals or executing
tasks they are in the middle they are
connecting and once you have that you
have this beautiful thing which is
information
processing so you can from there you can
actually jump into the real big
complexity right and precisely because
some systems like I don't know plants
plants don't have neurons but they don't
have also anything equivalent to inter
neurons yeah okay information processing
elements right and because of that not
having that is an huge limitation in
many ways got it so I think again that's
a concept that I never really
appreciated the importance of so it's
relatively straightforward to imagine
the usefulness of neurons that sense
things likewise neurons that send out
instructions to the rest of the organism
but then there's a revolution when you
invent just neurons that only talk to
other neurons and can really therefore
process information that's their job yes
exactly yep when did that happen can we
can we pinpoint
that well
um probably I mean before the Cambrian
we we we for sure we had organisms that
have um Nets Nets of neurons not brains
not centralized control but Nets of
neurons like Hydra nowadays uh or or
other very simple organisms or like a
jellyfish so you you do have um a
network and you do have interneurons but
that is typically connected
with um things that have more to do with
Locomotion and not exactly complex
information processing but that means
that it was at the at the basis of the
of the Cent explosion also okay and I
guess that helps explain why the word
network keeps appearing in this kind of
discussion right I mean you have cells
they can do some things but hooking up
those cells in an array in a network is
a crucial step in truly processing
complex
information exactly because then then
again you can also have emerging
Behavior you can also store memories in
complex ways and and again processing
means that um you have are starting to
have access to a space in terms of of
Dimensions uh a big space of
possibilities whereas you have only
sensing and reacting U just limited to
respond to the environment in a in a
very predictable and simple way and this
is jumping ahead a a little bit but Des
uh uh despite the fact that there's a
lot of excitement about neural networks
and Ai and things like that I take it
that a typical computer architecture
like the laptop that I'm using to talk
to you with doesn't have this kind of
network structure right it's not there's
not subunits that you would recognize as
neurons it's more homogeneous like
there's a memory there's a CPU and
they're doing different
things yes the the logic architecture is
totally different this is the for noyman
AR architecture it's common to our
computers and has to do with something
that is easy to understand that in a way
uh typically information is being
process it in a sequential way and and
in a way that is extremely efficient
with with the hardware we have uh but
has very little to do but that's that
said I would like to mention that one
interesting thing that happened when
people started to build this um these uh
computers with a very dense arrays of of
microprocessors that interestingly one
thing that was found out is that
the the web of connections the the the
network that connected in a very
efficient way to to reduce costs and and
Signal processing um turns out to have
statistical properties that pretty much
identical to what we observe in parts of
the brain cortex okay and it's it's
again um as we were saying before if you
look for kind of universal laws
interesting to see that the engineers
who didn't know anything about the brain
cortex ended up in in in a scaling law
the Rens rule with the same kind of
behavior than parts of the the brain
cortex again suggesting that maybe there
are really Universal and you mentioned
the bment architecture is that distinct
from how a neural network
works it is it is totally because you
know in in a neural network you have on
the one hand um it's formed by elements
that that are um in the case of living
systems are are Polar Systems are
neurons and have a polarity that send
send signals from one part to another in
One
Direction um and are organized usually
in
multi-layers and information processing
is highly parallel something that
happens in the rail um but not in a
computer even in parallel computers
right okay whereas I mean maybe maybe
explain to our audience what the fyman
architecture is in contrast with that
kind of network point of
view well um fora architecture is
grounded in the fact that you have kind
of basic modules uh a central processing
unit to process information and memory
where you actually put the data ready
for being processed there and
essentially it's an architecture that we
identify very easily in in our computers
but I as I was saying before in a way is
inspired in the idea that you have to
deal with with software because that was
actually was the revolution that
happened in foran time yeah Forman was
the one who actually foresee that um and
the way of doing that for assistant of
this binary and and using the kind of
architectures we use the simplest nicest
and most powerful way is using that kind
of separation between processes okay but
uh nevertheless that so that sounds like
a sensible thing for human beings to
design when you first start designing
computers but you're hinting that you
know as we're pushing our capacities
more and learning new ways we're kind of
converging back on a more biological
networked
Vision uh yes um in fact we we wrote a
paper recently um that we we entitled
evolution of uh brains and computers the
wrote not taken and and in that paper
that I I wrote with one of my former
students we on it we argue that when you
look carefully at um the things that
artificial neural networks and that
includes the the most common things
we're using nowadays um when you look at
the way they work and the potential that
they have and what's really being
deliberate um we defend the idea that uh
probably in order to get into the real
General artificial intelligence
something that really matches what we do
you probably need to go through some of
the paths that our brains have followed
in evolution and and in particular there
are several things that I think that
extremely different and not yet there in
the machines that are kind of the
singularities of our brain one is
language complex language as much as you
see uh that they can use language is not
the same kind of thing
um the other is something that
fascinates me and is the is time
somebody said we are mental Travelers
right that um we on the one hand use
memory and the same architecture we use
for memory allows to do something
absolutely amazing which is thinking in
not one feature but many possible
features that is reev a revolution
really in out evolution of humans and
then this um apparently disconnected but
very important thing which is this
capacity of understanding the mind of
the others right of uh understanding
what the other is thinking so to speak
right because when you put these three
things in connection uh something really
singular happens yeah absolutely nothing
like that is in the artificial
intelligence that we have okay good I
I'd like to maybe expand on that a
little bit because I'm I'm a big
believer in the importance of the mental
time travel stuff we had Adam bully I
don't know if you know him but he was a
guest talking about how helps
distinguish human ways of thinking from
other people but the um you said the the
AI way of thinking is not the same kind
of thing so you just identified some
features that are true for human
cognition in what way is AI not doing
that because we all know I'm on your
side here but anyone who has interacted
with chat GPT knows that it sounds human
so how can it be sounding human if it's
doing something so
different well um I guess I guess it
depends who you ask um I like I like
this idea I mean I'm impressed by Chad
GPT I don't want to do this missive here
because I can't yeah um but it's it's
interesting to see that this system has
no past so it's it's no childhood or
learning or anything connected with
other um as a humans other people right
which the cultural part is is enormously
important but they have they have been
trained h in
making so to speak a a c cultural
compression
process that in in the way of doing
something apparently so trivial which is
predict the next word right because that
that comes from the idea yeah how do you
predict the next word but it turns out
that what happens is that and it's I
think it's important to try to
understand that that in the process of
optimizing this prediction they these
systems seem seems to have been
generating something that is kind of um
reasoning kind of something that mimics
reason yeah and I say mimic because of
course there's no
understanding but it's interesting to
see that for us the humans we are kind
of looking there and I was think in in
the orig origins of artificial
intelligence I mean I was thinking how
do we see uh uh the machine uh operating
and how do we interpret that and I I was
thinking when I was a student and there
was this program Eliza which was kind of
a very simple program right yeah but
even even for us I remember my
colleagues that we we we program that
and even for us knowing that it was no
intelligence there was nothing there
right but it's kind of something that
calls calls to your brain and kind of
have a feedback with with that machine
and Chad GPT of course has Amplified
this in ways that we we we didn't expect
um but again in terms of uh there's no
time there I mean clearly right uh and
actually you can actually test a little
chat GPT with questions and things about
time and see that there are some
troubles there um but as more as we move
more and more into big versions I mean
as clearly clearly the lands get BR yeah
gets better no we'll see we will see
okay let's let's get back to the to the
biology a little bit I'm not quite done
with that before we move on um cuz you
referred to the the kinds of structures
that are in ordinary biological brains
um I presume that what you're what
you're gesturing toward is the claim
that the brain is a scale-free system
that that it's on the edge of
criticality the edge of or it is
critical it's the edge of chaos if I'm
right about that supposition explain
what all that means and why it
matters okay um there's one clear thing
in the brain in terms of Dynamics um
which is um this critical State meaning
that um pathological brain States
looking at the Dynamics right things
that you can actually measure from E EES
or from any kind of non-invasive
invasive method right you have time
series of changes um in an epileptic
state or in some kind of um pathological
State you see the the brain state much
more organized much more regular right
not good not good at all of
course whereas in you are in for example
coma States lock in States you see that
there's low activity much more random so
you have kind of disordered State uh we
don't want that of course and um the the
nice thing of the research has been
shown that the healthy brain seems to
operate on a critical state right on the
boundary of a phe transition
is ongoing discussion of what kind of
exact transition is going on there but
clearly it it happens to take advantage
of the regularities that you have
because you have internal oscillations
but
this amazing capacity you have the
critical point of reacting quickly into
into any kind of um stimula um that said
this is the dynamical uh State how this
is this connecting with
actual
cognition right
okay because for example language also
exhibits some features of uh scale-free
behavior um other other attributes that
you can find out seem also but um how
are they connected right this is
something because in principle you can
think in a in a in a an intelligence
that doesn't use
criticality
so so I me know you're kind of in
insinuating or implying that they are
connected uh but but maybe you're saying
we don't know yet we that's an a
conjecture yes yes we don't have yet a
good theory uh to kind of connect the
computational tasks uh as you will
describe a functional
cognition and and the Dynamics okay
don't have that yet good I mean maybe
one thing just to get clear for the
listeners cuz cuz you and I will use a
word like phase transition
uh but I bet that some people think that
that's a process unfolding in time right
like water boiling or ice melting and
that's not what you're saying is
happening in the brain I
presume no no no I mean we do we do
observe phase transitions in particular
in in some kind of experiments that you
prepare for people for example looking
at an object that has two two different
interpretation you can see the range
flipping between different state but
it's more like uh at right the F
transition where you have this critical
State um you kind of leave there you
stay there and again that's an
interesting thing that seems common to
other systems right like AR viruses that
leave on the age of catastrophe right in
the order on Disorder so seems to life
kind of lives it yeah and it I'm never
completely clear on whether that should
be obvious or surprising in the sense
that you know there's there are more
ways for the brain to be either
completely disordered or completely
ordered like there seems to be some need
for regulation to keep it right at this
critical point where there's something
going on at very different light scales
and time
scales right I mean it's it's um as I
said since we still lacking a a theory
as as for example we lack a theory a
neural theory of of language right which
is something that we would really need
to figure out at a bot um I like I like
the idea that actually Langton and
others kind of introduced many years ago
that computation in in complex systems
in competition in biology in particular
um needs to occur somewhere where you
can take advantage of the order that you
need to store information and have you
know regularities that are predictable
but on the other hand kind of be
open-ended and able to actually
manipulate information and probably the
the boundaries with order and disorder
is what this happens and and and for a
physicist the natural language is
thinking that you are on the on the
border this face transition between
border and Disorder so let's start then
applying this to trying to figure out
the space of cognition so the these are
um examples of of brains and and neural
systems and we're kind of familiar with
that you want to say that there's a
whole another world out there that these
are solid brains and what about the
liquid
brains yeah yeah yeah the liquid brains
is a is a whole story we think for
example we tend to think in humans that
you we have been unfortunately for our
planet we've been very very successful
uh in in one of the reason for that is
that we are what we call inequality
ecosystem Engineers we are been able to
manage to transer the planet changing
the flows of energy and matter to
massive scales it's interesting that uh
we have a competitor here which is
social insects termites in ANS as as
Edward Wilson said if if humanss were
not here that would be the planet of the
ants because they they also we don't
realize that they they are another kind
of intelligence that has been able to do
also a uh ecological engineering on
massive
skills um interesting that and and I
want to point out when people thinks
about intelligence in the universe uh
there maybe planets were in elligence
have emerged but it's liquid and liquid
intelligence cannot be as complex as the
solid one so there's not going to be
signals being sent from the those
planets anywhere but that doesn't mean
that it's not intelligent of course
right and that can be extremely
successful in in transforming the planet
so in in that respect one of the things
we been investigating precisely and
trying to do a wot theory of that is
what is the power of liquid Brains
Brains formed by individuals that move
around which in a way are as then then
then it said is brain to brains right
because every every you fact has has a l
brain so by liquid because I think that
people are going to be imagining a glass
of water or a cup of coffee and you
you're imagining in your mind uh a a
colony of ants or of termites they're
liquid in the sense that the individual
pieces
move around and interact differently
with each other unlike the neurons in
your brain exactly and so there's no
there's no individual identity between
between Pairs of ants there's not such a
thing as a connection between two given
ants that in a way is stable is not such
a thing and that totally changes the
landscape of possibilities but the same
happens with the immune system immune
system is a fluid neural network and
it's able to learn it's able to store
memory of course with a very well
defined functionality right dealing with
pathogens but it is uh a network and in
fact if you make a model of theion
network it's not much different from a
standard new network okay I don't know
yeah yeah it is I can tell you and so
it's interesting to see that on
different scales you actually can find
out for example we an organism another
neural network that is is in this case
liquid and and it's also the question
for example with some uh some
particularly interesting things like the
microbiome right that this huge
ecosystem that we carry out inside and
that in a way makes makes the the claim
that we are a single species uh kind of
nonsense because we are carrying out a
whole a whole ecology and we know the
microbiome which is just you would say
just bacteria but they communicate with
the immune system and in directly with
the brain so you see the separation
between the sonit and the liquid is not
so simple because it may be that they
kind of interconnect okay but you just
said uh provocatively that the liquid
brains are not going to be as
intelligent as the solid ones and I
might have thought that the sort of
extra flexibility of having the ants
move around and talk to each other gives
the capacity of potential more
intelligence than the fixed hard wiring
in our
brains it could be great but um think
about uh what the ant colony or the
termite Colony does if in evolution it's
uh it's it emerging of this
superorganism that in a way warrantees
to think about the same idea of how do
you reduce the uncertainty of the
environment how do you predict one way
of doing that is creating a nest having
a a internal environment that is stable
but the ultimate goal here is to
reproduce the whole story that's that's
why uh the the life cycle of an nest of
an unolon you want is so similar of the
one of a of a multicellular organism
okay you have development from not a
single cell but from a queen and then
this grows you need to monitor your
environment where until you have
resources um but all the cognition in a
way it's placed in in in the colony
reproduction and being able to actually
you know uh be able to reduce
uncertainty this our brains does it in a
way they do it in a lot of way but but
has this an amazing potential for memory
and that's just because neurons have
identity yeah okay a pair of neurons
have a special identity if you destroy
that um we have kind of a proof of that
the potential for storing for example
memories is extremely reduced I see all
right so then in that case let me just
ask the skeptical question here are we
even playing fair by talking about ant
colonies or termite colonies as brains I
mean do they live up to the to the um
implications of of being compared with
the human
brain well that of course I mean one of
the reasons that we came about with this
term when we we made we made this this
work working group at the Santa Fe
Institute and the idea was how how do we
map the space of Cl how do we label
things in a way that is Meaningful and
provides kind of basic categorization
what is that
um I can I can understand your question
because you know say brain is is a big
claim but on the other hand I mean uh
you still you have a system that can
stop information process information
because there is information processing
right um and in a way it will be kind of
unfair uh not allow them to do that I
must say that if I I have to tell you
the truth um this comes from when I was
a an undergraduate student and I was
reading half's book oh yeah get the
lecture back and I was I mean I I was in
love with the idea that you know uh an
an colony in a brain uh uh kind of
relate very related things so what could
they do yeah what can you do do ant
colonies talk with other ant
colonies no they they they fight with
all the an colonies okay okay they don't
they don't gang together to end Colony
societies as far as we know no no no
they don't they don't do friends that
way in other instead they can expand
some some species of ants can expand
over you know vast areas going through
entire countries right super colonist
okay all right well good to know um so
that sounds like an
Axis or you know one coordinate on the
space of cognitions liquid versus solid
right so I guess one question is are
there gases and and other uh forms in
that particular Dimension and then
secondly are there other dimensions
yeah as you know in biology um some in
some way as as a different from physics
you will find
exceptions and there are there are um
organisms in our list that in a way look
like out layers one of them is fum fum
is this this kind of um mold that is a
single cell but you can see you can see
it with the naked eye it can be as big
as this table uh this yellow it's just
kind of a extraterrestrial thing yeah
it's a little
creepy yeah yeah totally creepy and it's
it's a single cell in the sense that
there there's um there's a single Mass
it's a lot of nuclei inside the cell um
and in nature they they can they can
manage to uh it's always moving around
and spreading it's it's again between
liquid and solid because it's it's
clearly they maintain a lot of structure
but this fluctuating and chaining all
the tile this as they organize if you
look close and make a picture seems like
a neural network because they have all
these very complex vation patterns as
they move around and they can detect
sources of food and make decisions about
which one is the richest and go in go
when I say go mean changing morphology
to exploit that Source in the most
efficient way and and somebody thought
okay let's use that because uh what if I
put two food sources like and they they
like flakes so it is easy to maintain
and I put them in the entrance and the
exit of a maze oh yeah and I put F there
because I can cut into pieces Etc and in
the end Fano fluctuates changes changes
changes and in then you have a single
tube that goes the optimal path from
entrance to exit right so there are two
things to say one is the Beautiful thing
and so why is this so different is that
the computation is the shape so really
morphology is what says I I made this
optimization this is the solution so
it's nothing similar to that anywhere
yeah the other thing because sometimes
this is s like well look Fon solves
mathematical problems or well yes but
it's the humans who Define the boundary
conditions and that's that's a big
difference right I put the laby here and
I put out there and fadum exploits this
special capacity that has in a way is
least action this is what is happening
here it's kind of finding out the the
shortest path and and you can use that
but we have to be aware that um it can
solve problems if we do prepare the
problems prop right it's not like it's
smart and goes in the forest doing
calculations right and this is you're
you're using the correct name for this
Beast D but we is this what we call a
slime mold uh
informally isn't isn't the same class
yes same class as slime because I know
these stories of slime mold solving
mazes and it is a little creepy but it's
a good example of a different kind of
cognition so okay so
there's there are examples that span the
space from liquid to solid and and and
in between so if we're mapping out the
multi-dimensional space of cognitions
what other things should we be thinking
about other than the liquid
solidity
transition well plants plants are are of
course extremely important elements here
because plants have evolved in a way
that if you thinking what I said before
that movement is something that has been
the engine of of building brains and
evolving brains PLS do not move plants
have this special status that they can
another energy just from the Sun you
don't have to move they have an enormous
morphological plasticity meaning that if
I ask you how many organs you have you
just can count them because it's it's
totally regular how many organs has a a
plant and since every single leaf is is
an organ uh but can they they can appear
and disappear um it's totally flexible
it depends what you need and and that
makes it and always different from
anything they don't have neurons nor
anything has been claims on that not
anything similar so my my position about
that is that plans that are absolutely
amazing they really have terraformed
their planet and on and they are
spectacular in many ways I don't think
they like modert it's I think it's it's
a different story okay very good uh so
but what about like different
organizational architectures you've
talked about the critical brain um are
there is that just the single right
thing to do if you want to be
intelligent or are there other ways of
of achieving this that might that
biological whether real or hypothetical
biological systems might contemplate
doing oh okay um well I wanted to
mention that also in an colonies at
least in some species we observe also
the critical State see fluctuations of
activity that that mat very well that um
in in flocks of birds uh the ways they
change in shape it's been very well
characterized they live in the critical
State they will move
around criticality so in a way that you
see changes that are very predictable
that they're absolutely ready for any
kind of external signal to react
immediately um what other kinds of
things you find out um I have I have
made the conjecture that um and I want
one of the things I'm doing as part of
my research trying to put this in a
formal way right
that anything that is evolvable into
cognition uh will be characterized by
two things one is that as we mentioned
before the fact that you have elements
that are thres elements so that when you
send a signal you you wait how strong it
is and you react all or nonone depending
on how how big is the is the signal as
neuros for example um and you will have
a multi-layer
and again one of the reasons that I
don't think it's a it's a kind of a
surprised that Engineers building these
artificial Neo networks keep using what
you have been finding out in in in the
ray cortex example the the multi-layer
structure of the visual
cortex neurons that are FAL elements
yeah can you escape from that really
because I I don't think you can't and
another thing that helps to actually
make a good argument is that you know
this is whole area of artificial life
where in principle in silico you got a B
thing that could be absolutely different
from anything you find out in nature why
do we don't find any kind of a cognitive
system that in a way deviates from what
we
see I bet that this is because they are
Universal things yeah I mean that's one
of the two options the other option is
that we're just not that imagin
and so therefore we keep Reinventing
what we are familiar with
right well but again um I think
artificial life uh it's it's one way of
actually um getting this this taste that
it's not as it's probably the the
constraints that are there and I want I
want to also make the point that why uh
in in the neural networks of the brain
we see multi-layers of thres of elements
and and then when you go into inside
cells you look at how genes interact
with each other how what kind of me
models you make you you make models with
thresold element responses and Mayes and
why immune system when you make a model
of the the network of immune cell
interactions is a thresold network with
sometimes multi-layers it's it's a bit
suspicious well good so I've heard
people mention this but you're
emphasizing it more strongly so that's
very interesting the idea
of a threshold element you know you have
some input but your output is not just
proportional to how much input you have
it's like you get no output for a little
bit of input and then a lot of output
for more there's a threshold that you
cross so what is it that makes that so
crucial to this kind of architecture why
is that so good why is this nonlinearity
so
important well I guess that I don't have
a a complete answer for that there's
something named yeah but we really AAL
elements means that you can perform the
simplest way of integrating signals or
making a decision whether or not a
majority of uh input signals crosses a
given boundary if you isolate that just
from one neural receiving input from
everyone else that's not very meaningful
but if you think in the network where
different parts of the network have to
wait what's the state of the system
thres elements are really really an
efficient solution okay maybe the only
one good yeah so that presumably leads
us to lessons for constructing life and
cognition whether it's in AI or robots
Etc are these are are the lessons there
clear yet or are we still learning
them oh we're still learning I mean
there's been um beautiful achievements
within artificial intelligence in the
past for example in in relation with
language and sometimes showing you that
emergence and and I I do think that is
the key that emerging phenomena is going
to be the really relevant story here
like many years ago Luke steals was
working with these robots that exchange
words inventing words and and preaching
agreements and in the end you get um a
situation where your robots have made a
lexicon to refer to the world which was
more or less programmed but surprise
there in order to make sense of the
world they invent a protog grammar which
is emergent it wasn't it wasn't planned
so it's it's kind of a I think an
interesting uh insight into thinking of
if we allow artificial intelligence
systems into have opportunities for for
example having embodiment embodiment is
so important in in actually reaching
cognition um maybe we will see big
advances right uh but right now the the
machines or the networks just leaving
this uh I used to say they Le kind of a
in the dark rues with no world right the
world doesn't exist and they have no
body of course right well we have had
people on the podcast talking about uh
symbolic versus connectionist approaches
to Ai and the idea of the AI building a
model of the world versus just trying to
predict the you know what what word
comes next next in the sentence and
there is this weird tension because the
successful implementations have been
mostly connectionist right you know just
huge neural networks that you feed a lot
of data into and let it try to predict
the next sentence but my impression is
that they don't actually have a model of
the world inside and that that seems
like a kind of limitation but I know
that that's also controversial in the
field it is controversial yes um yeah I
mean they don't have they don't have a
model the thing is as I was saying
before um we don't we cannot ignore the
fact that since we do have models of the
world and we have a we can have a theory
of mind um it's important to think that
in the future artificial intelligence is
not going to be just um what people is
expecting the real intelligence um I I
use this example from from this movie
always recommend I'm I'm a very movie
person um
um Robot and Frank okay which is it's an
amazing story about this this person
that has starts Alzheimer and the kids
uh bring uh a robot and it's clear from
the beginning the robot is not
intelligent and uses natural language
that makes a big difference and changes
because it learns right but it it's not
intelligent and it's is a scene that I
really I really find so fascinating
where the the robot is saying uh Frank
eras my memory I don't I know you don't
like it uh but you don't like to hear
that by not a person and that's the case
but it doesn't change the fact that um
as it happens maybe with our pets for
example right where communication is is
actually very limited it doesn't it
doesn't matter much really because uh in
a way it's kind of looking oursel in a
mirror that is evolving in time as if he
was someone else
uh hey we Haven weight much what will be
the implications of
that good so um I guess to connect
before to to what you said before about
embodiment uh we're going to I it won't
take too long I imagine before we are
taking the AIS that we've built the
large language models and embodying them
right and putting them in robots and
giving them bodies and maybe even the
scary part to me is giving them hunger
giving them desires to you know get
resources out there in the world to
persist is that is that a thing that is
coming and should we be
scared I I don't I don't think we should
be scared for for one reason we
mentioned the the right thing uh could
could be scary if in a way there are
goals or emotions or or in a way kinds
of uh potential responses that have to
do with some that are very human like I
I I always find funny this all this
discussion about the artificial
intelligence that will kill us but my
question is why why yeah what is the
motivation for that right and for human
is natural because as I was saying
before we have can have a theory of mind
we can understand the the how the others
think in a way right we put yourself in
the mind of another and that was
probably the origin of Consciousness if
I can say selection pushes into
understanding standing the mind of the
others you are equi it with language the
the the brain time machine it's for me
it's almost inevitable that in the end
you you understand that you are also a
special individual in a world and you
understand yourself so sorry I'm I'm
kind of moving around no that's good you
should but you're that it's sort of
charmingly optimistic uh you know I I'm
probably on your side but I guess the
opposite argument would be how much risk
are you will going to
take as I said I mean um intentions is
something that's really has to do with a
a layer of commission that I think
escapes completely right right now uh
for artificial intelligence is not it's
not there right so you you don't have
any kind of motivation uh which is a
really high level complex scle thinking
um why you should be harmful at all okay
so by thinking about the space of
cognitions liquid and solid brains and
things like that are we led to realize
that there are possible cognitions that
we haven't yet explored and can we build
them either in uh silicon or even
biologically well that's that's
something that um I'm very interested
for one reason um when we build this
space of cognition we have several
candidate uh ways of drawing this um we
use cubes in in evoltion anology they
known as the morphos spaces okay you try
to find out axes that represent relevant
properties for example how complex is is
the computational power of one of these
systems um how autonomous it is or in
the vertical axis for example how social
it is and it's interesting that if you
put there all the objects you know which
means animals from oopy to humans and
hands and also robots and uh AI systems
there's a big void there's a domain
there that is
empty why is that right it it happens
like in physics that sometimes you find
out this in in a space of face space you
have this is this is
forbidden is it forbidden or is
something that we haven't actually
observed or maybe can be engineered
right that's that's how the fascina
questions that has emerged from the
research well we're late in the podcast
so you are allowed to speculate what do
you
think um well my experience from another
system which is um morphogenetic systems
so we have been also since we have a
synthetic biology weab we can actually
play with some things and one of the one
of the spaces that we created we also
had a boid a big boid of morphologies
that we couldn't observe but we were
able to engineer some which means that
um for us there was a path that maybe
Evolution was unable to follow but we
could could do it is it going to happen
with
cognitions um that's one of the most
fascinating things that comes out from
the research like you know finding out
that this is this is an empty place um
why is that right maybe maybe something
that we can invent or maybe it's
forbidden um
so maybe just for the audience a little
more about the synthetic biology aspect
of this so you're you're going in as
intelligent designers and editing the
DNA and making new
organisms okay well it let's not use the
term intelligent designers just in case
you should
do well the thing is synthetic biology
allows us to interrogate nature in very
interesting ways I mean it's is a
powerful tool for biomedical research
it's it's an amazing way of actually
um playing with living cells um for us
as as complexity theories actually it's
it's a new way of actually asking
questions like for example if I want and
this is an ongoing project if I want to
transform bacteria modify genetically in
such a way that they behave like
ants um ants can solve problems because
they communicate in special ways for
example they can find the shortest path
to with the nest in a given source of of
uh food could we tickle uh bacteria and
if we can why is that right because
bacteria could benefit from having extra
cognition to do yeah some things again
uh doesn't seem to be the case is
because Evolution couldn't get there or
because there are tradeoffs uh that it's
it's not worth to actually develop more
cognition so it's amazing way of
actually um kind of creating things that
solutions that nature hasn't found yeah
and see how far can you go yeah good so
plenty of work to be done I I I like
that I'll give you one last uh thing to
speculate about since we again rela in
the podcast if a colony of ants can be
thought of as a collective intelligence
you know at what point does a group of
human beings become a collective
intelligence you know is is Spain
conscious well uh I I think it's not the
thing I will say I will say two things
one Edward Wilson said very well
something which is from the point of
view of a society we have nothing to
learn from ants right sometimes it's
easy to think that it's it's analogies
but I have to be very careful with that
um
well I mean
sometimes it's so disappointing to see
humans behave that it's it's this
collective intelligence I I you think
that is is not not going to happen um
there's clearly an amazing an amazing
thing that has to do with some
collective phenomena here which is the
the culture culture has made has been
coevolving with brains for humans right
and and I like it when Michael lman the
Santa Institute told me that we were
discussing about the tradeoffs that you
see that um it seems that the more
complex is an organism in a
society the the less the less social is
the whole system whereas if Society
insects is huge the individuals turn to
be more stupid yeah but he don't look
but look at humans I mean if you isolate
this amazing human brain from the
rest is absolutely useless it's worth
nothing right because isolated from
culture from from learning from
imitation from language acquisition uh
whatever we nothing really interesting
just something to make to make makes you
think about about how culture and brains
go evolved right so groups are not
really uh groups of human beings are not
themselves conscious but we do rely on
their their input uh and social social
interactions to make us who we are know
and and it's clearly um being social
it's part of the the the fact that we
have Co operating agents and that was a
huge part of our success as a species
despite that as I was saying before some
days it doesn't seem to be the case I
was going to say I hope we can keep up
that success for a little while longer
so Ricard soai thanks very much for
being on the mindgate podcast thank you
very
[Music]
much
w